when we're thinking about how economies
work the tricky thing is that their
systems and you look at any particular
corner of the system and you're gonna
miss the big picture but the big
pictures complicated really complicated
so what I wanted to try to do was to
find examples of simple economic systems
the systems that were simple enough you
could see all the moving parts working
and you can understand how recessions
worked and there were a couple of
examples that I found one is not so
famous it's an example of a recession in
a prison camp and the other is a lot
more famous because Paul Krugman's
talked about it and that's a babysitting
co-op recession and these aren't
hypothetical examples these aren't kind
of you know textbook imaginary things
these recessions actually happened and
in the case of the babysitting co-op
recession it was Capitol Hill Washington
DC the late 1970s it was written up in a
Lerner journal and what happened was
parents who joined this babysitting
circle there were about 400 of them they
were trying to keep track of who was
looking after whose kids and it's
difficult to keep all that straight on a
spreadsheet remember this is the 70s so
you don't have Microsoft Excel so they
had these little tokens and they'd pass
these tokens around and if you you
looked after somebody's children then
you would be given a token and then when
you wanted someone to look after your
children you would give them a token and
those how they had this currency and
that's great except what happened was
when people were joined the babysitting
co-op they were given these tokens and
they didn't have quite enough not enough
babysitting could be bought with what
they had so they thought to themselves
why don't I go and babysit for somebody
else a few times and then I'll have a
good stack of these tokens and then once
I have a good stack of these tokens then
I'll start going out myself and hiring
babysitters the trouble is everybody in
the babysitting co-op was doing exactly
this and if everybody in the babysitting
co-op was doing
this then no one's able to get a job
babysitting because everyone's just
trying to work for everyone else now
there are a number of possible solutions
to this one is that people would just
agree hey this this token that we've got
that's worth an hour's babysitting let's
say it's worth two hours babysitting
let's say you could buy twice as much
babysitting with this token and that
could potentially solve the problem but
that's not what people did people die
think felt uncomfortable renegotiating
the contract so a second thing you could
do and they tried this was to legislate
how often people had to go out so they
came up with this rule that people had
to go out at least twice a year now I
don't have a really hectic social life
you know I've got three children I'm an
economist you know I don't go out that
much but you know even I think that
going out twice a year is not that much
and if that's your baseline that's going
to kick start the babysitting economy
you have a problem in the end the
babysitting recession committee or the
babysitting committee solved the problem
by simply issuing more of this currency
they they printed more of these little
tokens they handed more out they handed
more out to people when they arrived
they took fewer away from people when
they left the babysitting co-op and that
worked beautifully that kick-started the
whole thing and this massive long
lasting recession suddenly evaporated
which is great
then they printed too many they had a
hyperinflation problem and the economy
crashed again but that just goes to show
it's not easy to run an economy now I've
been fascinated by these these two
simple cases of economists at went wrong
and one the babysitting co-op very
famous so what's the other one the other
one is what I call the prison camp
recession and again this really happened
this was a recession that took place in
a second world war prison camp and it's
a very different kind of recession to
the babysitting co-op and that and
that's why I think it's interesting so
what happened was this was a an economy
there was an economy in this prisoner of
war camp
it was mostly based on exchange food
would come in from the International Red
Cross and be bred there'd be medicines
there'd be coffee there'd be cigarettes
these parcels would arrive and prisoners
would trade them so some people didn't
eat meat some people the English wanted
tea the French wanted coffee people
wanted different things and there was a
little bit of production that took place
in the camp as well so people would
polish each other's boots or offer to
fix up suits or uniforms do stitching or
there was even a guy who had a food cart
he'd sell tea he'd sell coffee he even
had an accountant working for him so
there was this this economy and this
prisoner of war camp now what's
interesting about this economy is it
worked incredibly well under the
circumstances it was very sophisticated
so there was a futures market for bread
you know you could buy bread now or you
could buy bread on Tuesday and the price
you know buy pay now for bread to be
delivered on Tuesday and the price of
those two things was different
there was an export market so at the
time Germany this prison camps in
Germany with Allied prisoners the
Germans couldn't get coffee
well the prisoners were getting coffee
sent to them by the Red Cross so there
was this market price for this coffee
and the coffee would go over the fence
and be exported to Germany and be sold
in black-market cafes a very
sophisticated economy only one thing
those prisoners nearly starve to death
and the reason they nearly starved to
death wasn't because of any flaw in the
way that economy worked but because of
an external shock and it's not hard to
see what the external shock is the Red
Cross food parcels stopped arriving
because the war had got so soon severe
that they couldn't get through anymore
now that sounds like a really extreme
example and of course in many ways it is
but it actually illustrates a very
important disagreement in economics so
that there are economists who focus a
lot on the idea that the the economy
itself malfunctions gets out of
equilibrium maybe because prices don't
move and they would look to the
babysitting co-op as their totemic
example the New York Times columnist
Paul Krugman does this it's a great way
of explaining how a recession can happen
because an economy get stuck internally
and when the economy gets stuck
internally you need a government to come
in and give it a kickstart maybe some
kind of stimulus prison camps
different the prison-camp reflects an
economy that was working perfectly well
prices are adjusting everything's
working brilliantly but there's this
shock that comes from outside the system
and in the real world that shock could
be a change in China's trade policy it
could be a change in oil prices it could
be a shock from the financial system you
know hitting the real economy in the
manufacturing and services the banking
crisis hits us from the outside and if
that's what's going on then a government
stimulus program won't necessarily help
you government can't necessarily get
things started because fundamentally
there's nothing wrong with the economy
the economy is working fine it's just
that something we were hit by an
asteroid the economic equivalent to an
asteroid so when you hear economists
arguing about whether there should have
been a stimulus program whether there
should still be a stimulus program what
they're really arguing about is is the
American economy more like the
babysitting co-op or is it more like
with prison camp